hello dear cate munity
today it's about the topic of feed conversion
sometimes must
or would we like to change the food of our cats
be it for health reasons
Age or simple
to protect them from inferior
Switch to high quality feed
but how is it best
restart with the mix of about 25 percent
and 75 percent used to food
this gives your rent the opportunity
adapt to the new taste and consistency
to get used about every 2 to 3 days
you increase the share of the new food
by about 25 percent
until you finally get to 100 percent
of the new food have arrived
every cat is unique
some take longer
some get used to it more quickly
is important that you look for possible problems
or respect rejection
also the change can sometimes 1
take little time
especially
if your cat already Long at 1 certain food
is used to
but with patience and love you can do it
and 1 small tip on the side
1 little of favorite snack
a little tuna water or homemade chicken broth
about the new lining
can sometimes work wonders
and always thinks about it
the most important thing is
that our four-legged friends are healthy and happy
with love patience and the right food
we are on the best way